hi
chairman good afternoon
members officers and members of the
public welcome to this southeast
planning area meeting
on wednesday the 2nd of september my
name is councillor michael helm
and i'm vice chairman of this committee
deputising for councillor richard dewick
the chairman
this meeting is held under new covid
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april
in response to the kovic 19 pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please can i ask everyone
present at this meeting to ensure your
microphone
is muted and your video feed
will not goes off when not addressing
the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and being present in the
meeting you are giving your consent to
being recorded
members and officers during this each
item please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak burner will then
invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function
should not be used for questions or any
other purposes
members when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers please reference a
page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn your microphone and video on
now i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr lee mr lee
thank you chairman i am matthew lee lead
specialist for place here at morgan
district council thank you
thank you michael johnson
thank you chairman michael johnson lead
specialist development management
thank you ann king
good afternoon chairman i'm annie keane
senior caseworker
development management thank you louise
staplehurst
good afternoon chairman i'm louise
staplehurst and i'm a specialist in
development management
thank you uh burner is there anybody
else a burner and then anybody else
no no chairman i don't believe there's
anybody else bernard casey
clark to this afternoon's committee
thank you thank you berna can you
could you please put me down with being
in attendance
yes we would do that after the roll call
councilor maurice thank you
thank you chairman uh members i will
call your name in alphabetical order as
usual councillor bassinger
good afternoon berna i am present thank
you very much counselor
president good afternoon everyone
councillor bell
i'm present good afternoon everyone good
boys
here channel
i am present um good afternoon everyone
cancer fluker president
council helm mr president councillor
hall
good afternoon everybody thank you
stamp present burner thank you
now may i ask those members in
attendance to please introduce
themselves
lovely thank you very much thank you
chairman
my now have the apologies for absence
please berna
yes we've had a received apologies for
absence from councillor dueck
okay
sorry we'll carry on with the meeting
this is recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on the 5th of august
2020 founded on pages 7 to 16 are
approved and choose accurate record
iso move if you wish to second the
motion
turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
please
is there anyone going to say happy
second happy 2nd
councillor helm
okay thank you very much reed
we've all agreed right
declarations of interest now i believe
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosure of pecuniary interests
other than
other pecuniary interests and
non-pecuniary interests relating to isis
of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if any member has
an interest to declare please use the
chatbot let berna know
and indicate now and i will invite you
to speak
yes chairman caster fluker and
councillor channel would like to sit
there
i'll take councillor first ladies first
um thank you chairman um yes i must
declare non-pecuniary
um interest as a member of essex county
council because they're consulted on
matters to do with highways access
education anything else under the
planning remit and i did note in one
report they were actually specifically
referred to regarding some issue to do
um with waste chairman um i think that
might have been a gender item number
eight and i'll also declare regarding a
gender item number seven and
gender item number eight non-pecuniary
um i
am aware or rather know the agent
casper thank you chairman uh general
item seven i know the agent generator
mate
i know the agent and the applicant and i
declare in the interests of openness and
transparency thank you
okay anymore uh mr chairman mr chairman
i'd like to object to that i'd like to
know if that's a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest
and not just openness and transparency
please
please okay councillor bassinger
non-pecuniary
but secretary ismat does allow you
you know declare in the interest of
openness and transparency
thank you thank you very much we'll move
on to item number five
twenty double o four double one ful
land south of red lions lodge burnham
road lexington
[Music]
found on pages 17-32 please note that as
a members update
in relation to this application has also
been circulated
prior to the meeting in the moment i
will call on officers to present the
item
members and remind you that if you wish
to speak on this item please use
let burner know and i'll invite you in
please keep your points clear and
success ms king
would you like to present the report
thank you chair
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a new dwelling and cartilage
garage with a studio above
this application is a resubmission of a
previously approved application for the
same style of dwelling
this is the location plan showing the
proposed site
this is the proposed block plan showing
the location of the proposed dwelling
and cart lodge garage and studio the out
building and stable block indicated
either outbuildings referred to in
condition six and the report
the block plan in the corner shows the
proposed location of the previously
approved dwelling
as you can see it's in the same position
as the current application
this is the ground floor plan
[Music]
and the proposed first floor plan
is the proposed guard studio ground
floor plan
and the studio first floor plan above
the garage
this is the proposed northwest
elevations
and opposed south eastern elevations
there's the proposed garage elevations
with the studio above
this is previously approved application
um block plan showing
position of the dwelling and the
previously approved
elevations
and these are the photographs of the
site showing the entrance
and views to the north east and south
west
the application is recommended for
approval
and an additional condition regarding
soft landscaping is also proposed
um amendments to condition six
of the reports would specify the
buildings that are to be retained
thank you chairman thank you very much
mr keane
the recommendation to set up with the
report is as follows
the planning application 2004 double one
ful lounge south of red lions lodge
burnham road
latchington be approved some conditions
less detail in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now please
i'll second that's councillor boyce
thank you councillor boyce
uh i'll now invite members to make any
comments i think we should start with
the ward members as councillor boys and
councillor passenger
councillor boyce um thank you chairman
um um i agree with the officer
recommendation
that um it is um a site that has been
previously
um uh agreed and i see no
sound planning reasons to go to go
against that
or this recommendation and i propose a
recommendation
oh well sorry i second did it thank you
chairman
thank you council passenger would you
like to comment uh thank you mr chairman
no
no comment only i agree totally with
councillor boyce
and i also um approve this
recommendation
okay lovely yes
yes cancer channel would like to speak
to china
uh yes thank you very much thank you
very much chairman
um chairman actually i do have some
concerns about this application now
um we're being told there was a previous
approval in 16 well i believe that was
under the
the old local development plan as we
know our
adopted plan now um was done later than
that
and it seems to be the report refers to
that all the while and saying what was
approved it appears to me from the
report there's been no
technical start effectively i now
believe this does contravene our
our adopted local plan and i do have
real issues
i mean the building itself is massive
we're talking here something about
over 70 feet um you know
25.9 meters which is over 70 feet
and massive depth and also regarding the
garage
so now we're looking they haven't
actually got a permission to my
knowledge
of three years has gone so that's
disappeared from what i can see with no
technical start
this has to be taken to me on its own
merits as a new application
under our local um adopted plan that we
have
which was later than the 16 application
so therefore i don't see that we can
apply
the policies of that plan now to that
that was the old replacement local plan
so i have grave concerns about this
bearing in mind our five-year housing
land supply and bearing in mind what we
are seeking as a district in terms of
um buildings coming forward about two
beds required
um so chairman i i do would like some um
responses also to not apply the rams to
this i've read the report
we're now seeing uh other people having
the rams stuck on and having to have
agreements regarding rams before they
get a permission
it seems to be that the office is saying
on this one and no
i'm not criticizing the officer but
saying that no um
financial contribution should be given
on this well to me for my reason stated
to me this is a wholly new application
we can't apply that that's had a
previous um approvals um or before that
we have to start again new under our
local development plan and i have grave
misgrievings now about this application
chairman for those reasons
i've stated thank you can i have a
comment from a planning officer please
thank you chairman um to a certain stink
counselor channel is correct the
application is contrary
to the local development plan but as
members will know
that as decision makers we need to
assess every application in court for
the development plan unless material
indications
indicate otherwise um plan information
was granted
i think it was that appeal if i'm honest
um in
2016 um
for development of the site for dwelling
um
and as the office report in section 5.1
under principal development explains
although the 5.1.3 although the proposed
development is a departure from the
development plan
considerations should be had to the
three previous approvals replacements
dwellings on the site
due to these previous approvals the
principle the new dwelling has been
established and accepted
um the applicant states that the
existing training has been demolished in
line with condition five
which would have been required but
there's condition presence so we
actually don't consider planning
permission has been
has expired on so he has expired on this
site but
we need to be able to assess harm and
the inspector
when allowing the 2000 appeal
in 2015-16 when it was off the cuff
accepted that this site was acceptable
for uh redevelopment
and the provision of dwelling and while
i can understand council channel's
points and is a consideration officers
consider that the
material consideration that is the
previous decision
is of substantial weight and should
weigh heavily in favor of the
proposal um in relation to rams
that's that's a more of a balanced
consideration i would think
grams relates to basically any decision
the local authority makes it's not only
in relation to planning applications
um but obviously one of the most obvious
examples of where the council needs to
look to mitigate harm
from additional uh residential
properties is obviously with
planning applications and through that
we've got the spd that we've been
working on
and financial contributions
what officers have considered is that
by granting this application there is no
additional harm
compared to what was granted
a number of years ago by the inspector
therefore if they had done everything
correctly they would be able to build
this house as it is now
without needing this application if all
the t's have been crossing all the ice
have been dotted
therefore officers consider that the
decision to grant planned permission
today
will not result in any additional harm
compared to
what legally could happen if
members disagree with this and think
that actually they should be
looking at um seeking a ram's
contribution
that's within the decision makers gift
it's not definitive
right or wrong in this instance it's a
planning judgment call
and if members think that there should
be a rams contribution then i would
suggest that members look to amend the
approval to be
delegated to officers subject to the
completion of a unilateral undertaking
for us
for the rams i think i've covered the
points they're probably in a little bit
more labour than necessary
thank you chairman thank you very much
anybody else who wants to speak
no chairman all right we removed some
recommendation
which is to approve secondly by
councillor boyce can you take the roll
call please
thank you members i will call your names
in alphabetical order can you indicate
four against abstain thank you
councillor bassinger or
casabill or
bell for with the rams condition
yes of course cancer
boys three chairman four that that's
that can't be we're voting on the
recommendation
yes i
so what councillor bells just said amend
proof
that that's different
okay so we're just we're just voting on
the officer's recommendation of approval
okay do you want me to start again
chairman just very quickly
clarity chairman again do you mind
chairman because
i totally agree with you bell said
okay unfortunately we we went with the
recommendation to approve
nothing was put in then so we cannot do
it now
unless we have a tag on record uh
afterwards
and can we do that no future no then
obviously they're voting on the
officer's recommendation if members
aren't happy with that because they
wanted the rams they should be voting
against the office of recommendation or
uh
amendments should have been put forward
yeah
that changes my vote then
can we start again please that's why i
was suggesting could we start again
please start again from the beginning
please okay so this is well sorry
chairman can i please ask why are we
voting again
should we not pro should we go with this
and have the vote and then if it goes
down do it again
what's the proper process here because i
will be voting against
obviously we're starting again because
there's a bit of confusion so it's easy
to start again and carry on and then
have arguments afterwards so we'll do it
now if it's all right right and are we
starting again then on the
officer's recommendation or with rams on
but we haven't had the proposals for
that
officer's recommendation because we have
a proposal before we start okay
the vote thank you
okay so we're taking the vote on the
office's recommendation of approval only
thank you councillor passenger
or councillor beal
councillor bell against
cancer voice for
the channel against
caster fluker
against
against the stamp
against thank you
chairman that's five in favor of the
recommendation five against the
recommendation and no
abstentions and i'll take the casting
vote and it will go through thank you
thank you right we'll move on to item
number six
middlefield caravan site uh
burnaby crouch application 2004
5 2 stroke ful
found on pages 33-42 please note the
members update in relation to this
application has also been
circulated prior to the meeting in a
moment i'll call on the officer to print
this item members
are reminded that if you wish to speak
on this item
please make it known to burner and i
will then
come to you in turn please keep your
points clear and sustained
mr johnson please
thank you chairman just just trying to
sort out
the uh sharing i had a business plan
come up on my screen
oh hang on i think i've now i've got
milfields now
okay oh is it is it up now yeah i had uh
yeah i had a business plan pop up before
us
because i can't actually see on my
screen
i can see it on the screen now right
there's a plan of the site and there's
uh
several things on the left-hand side all
right that's the plan of the site
looking good michael
[Laughter]
sorry just bear with me um
i'm normally on the other side so um
and i'm not as technical as my uh my
officers
um right thank you chairman um
this application proposes the removal of
condition 6
the winter in bird period on approved
planning permission
1800381 which was the direction of the
building to be used as offices
shop shower toilet facilities spa pool
facilities
and gym and formation of hard standing
etc in association with an existing
caravan site so we can
see i'll just um
get my laser pointer we can see the site
highlighted
here
right now here's a location plan and
here we see our site more specifically
outlined here
and members um are reminded and are set
out in the report
this site has a lawful use um as a
caravan
site and planning permission was granted
for
additional facilities as just set out
these are just a few simple slides we
have here because the application just
concerns
the removal of the condition what is not
the uh
consideration here is the proposal as
previously approved
so here we have an aerial view of the
site and its surroundings
i will probably at some point be just
referring back to
this area of view in identifying where
some of the photographs
which i'll go on to now will show so
here we have a view looking south
west and then just to go back to the
photograph that was a view looking in
this
direction here so over here
i'm going back to this view looking west
across site
let's just go back to the area of view
so that's looking towards
this area here
so can i just go back to this site here
so the condition is to remove that
condition that condition
was placed on the uh previous
permission as a precautionary measure in
terms of protecting
wintering birds over the particular
period
the applicant has sought this
removal of this condition because it was
considered that it's not necessary to
provide this precautionary protection
because
the site is not considered appropriate
for
[Music]
wintering birds over this period and as
members will
note the consultation response
from our ecology
council tea supports that position
and that is set out within the report
under the consultation
section so what members have in front of
us
is the proposal to remove the condition
officers recommend that it can be
removed without prejudicial the proposal
or the nature biodiversity
interest in the area thank you chairman
thank you very much um the
recommendations say and report
planning acquisition 20 000 452 full
mill fields caravan site
panama crutch be approved subject
conditions and details in section 8 of
this report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone state your name
now
anybody counselor bell second
thank you councillor bell uh thank you
i'll now invite
members through burner to make any
comments on the report
yep
would like to speak to this item could
we also ask members to keep their
microphones muted when not speaking as i
believe there's an echo on youtube at
the moment
thank you okay um
cast the skeins was it first
yeah yes um
well of course uh as you'll be aware the
um
this uh particular site has been the
source of lots of controversy
i've no point going into that you're all
familiar with it uh
it's a pretty unpopular idea in burnham
but uh it's been given planning for you
approval it's where we are but can you
there's something i don't quite
understand and you and i'm sure the
planning officers will
be able to help the rspb have said
that they haven't got a problem with
this my experience is that there are
uh birds wintering and indeed it's
become a bit of a haven for wildlife
can officers tell me if the rspb
visited and if they did did they visit
during winter months
officers please um
thank you chairman um i'm i'm not aware
that the rsp
had visited the site um in
carrying out the assessment of this
application uh
we saw the uh comments of our ecology
consultant
cetera at 7.3 in the report um who had
offered no objections
so in terms of that um question
counselor that's the
answer that i'm able to offer you thank
you chairman
uh who else was there now please
thank you um mr chairman yes
it's uh as councillor skane said some
views on this are well known but we're
not here to discuss that
now i'm there are no
this particular area there are no
over-entering birds in fact the nesting
bird season
is from march to august so
i'm not entirely clear where at what
point in the year
these works were supposed to be done if
they couldn't do it in the winter and
they couldn't do
in the summer i'm a little bit cross
because it does
feel like sometimes planners go oh
it's burning let's just stick an
overwintering bird's condition on it and
i would like to invite
um planning officers to burnham to maybe
get a little bit of a better
understanding of
the local ecology of where the specific
bird populations
migrating ones and um
ones that live here i forget the right
word sorry um
actually live so this particular area
which i'm very familiar with i'd visit
it every day
we're looking at spring and summer
nesting for birds not over wintering and
that is why
i have seconded the motion to support
this
thank you thank you does any officer
want to
comment further on councillor bell's
points
uh no chairman um um
i do welcome councillor bell's comments
um
and then i suppose if anything it would
be just really to reiterate what we said
already regarding the ecology
consultants comments
which is actually consistent with what
council bell had had mentioned
and i think that again the comments on
the 7.3 are quite clear thank you
chairman
i think it's quite usual to put that
condition on about winter birds where
anything is near
the water we had one at mayland and it
includes
seals but that was so far inland it
didn't make any difference but that's
what you do thank you right anyone else
burner
no no chairman oh sorry council skins
would like to come back on that item
please
uh not wishing to contradict council
bell but i've seen uh
both i've seen chaffinches and robins
which are wintering birds
down there during the winter so it does
really suggest to me they are
wintering i've not seen their nests i
hasten to add and i am concerned that
the rspb
doesn't appear to have actually visited
the site and makes me wonder
when we get these ecology reports
whether in fact
uh these consultees actually have the
time or
uh to actually come down and visit these
sites it is a concern for
thank you for that cancer skins uh we
now move to the vote
we have a recommendation to approve
secondly by councillor bell
uh bernie could you take the vote please
thank you chairman i members i will call
your names in alphabetical order can you
state clearly for
against abstain for the officer's
recommendation of
approval counselor passenger
paul reveal
four councillor bell four
as the boys four
channel four
four master helm
thank you chairman that's
sorry
nine four one against no abstentions
thank you chairman thank you very much
that's julie passed we move on now to
planning application 20 000 4 5 9 stroke
f2l
a big co house foxhole road southwest
jurassics
found on pages 43-54
in a moment i will call officers to
present this side to members a reminder
that if you wish to speak on this item
please make this known using the chat
function within the meeting
then i will ask you to come on burner
would ask you to come
please keep your points clear and
succulent
thank you miss king mr king
thank you chair
planning permission is sought for the
change of use of land from agricultural
to b8 storage and distribution
and the erection of a storage building
so this is the location plan
this is the site plan showing the scale
of the sites outlined in red
this the block plan showing the location
of a proposed building
and the area of land that would be used
for the b8 storage and distribution
these are the proposed elevations of the
open fronted
storage building
and this is the floor plan
and these are the photos of the site
showing the entrance from foxhole road
the current use of the site
and the open countryside beyond
the application is recommended for
refusal as there is no policy
consideration
that would support change of use of land
in this locality
and result in an unacceptable form of
development in the countryside
it's also considered due to the noise
the development would impact
on the neighboring amenity of the
dwelling to the east
thank you chairman thank you um
and we want anyone wishing to oh hang on
we've got to go through the thing first
tonight sorry
the recommendation with a report as
follows the planning application 2004
5 9 if you will at the house box
being refused from the reasons detailed
in section 8 of the report
if any members wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
and mute your microphone and state your
name now
second it chairman thank counsel channel
um board members are councillor bill and
councillor
fluker i believe yes counselor would
like to speak
yeah thank you chairman um chairman i
i've read this application i know this
site
very very well it's in my wall it's not
a million miles away from where i live
and uh i've visited the site many times
over the years because it's it's a
commercial site and there's all sorts of
businesses that are there but chairman i
want before i
talk to one two points and policy um i
just really wanted some clarification
because
as far as i can see the application
doesn't seek to introduce
new use of the greenfield site in the
country um
and not least of all is that it's it's
used as
um for commercial businesses now and
there's industrial buildings there
there's no end of stuff going on
um and if you visit the site you can see
no end of buildings i mean there's a lot
of photographs but i mean
i think my first question is chairman
having read the report
can the officer confirm that they
visited this site and they've actually
seen what's going on there
officers please
thank you chair obviously due to
restrictions we haven't visited
recently but there has been visits to
this site yes
thank you so much for clarity uh
councillor fluke chairman um the
applicant
has submitted an application that is a
change from agriculture to
uh b1 uh not sorry not b1 and
2. b8 sorry so that the applicant
acknowledges that there is a change of
use
about culture to be a industrial user
undergoing
okay so so thanks for that clarity and
thank you for confirming that the
no officer has visited the site in
relation to this planning application
because i think
if they had they they'd understand why
i'm slightly confused about this
um gemini i i also note chairman that
the parish council supports this and i'm
i'm i'm sure that council obey
might wish to comment on this as well
because it's been used for commercial
purposes from
for donkey's years decades i think um
certainly for as long as i can remember
which probably goes back 50 years
um so chairman i just wanted to talk um
just briefly to uh policy s1 um
and this is all about effective use and
land and delivering local services now
um i hear what um mr lee says about a
change of use from agriculture over to
commercial um i find that quite strange
because i also it was all commercial
it certainly doesn't look like farmland
to me and it's butted on one side but i
think what you'd call residential
cartilage
and on the other side by an industrial
site there's three industrial sites down
there
so you know is this policy s1 is it the
effective use of land do we want to
leave it as a small plot of agricultural
land
within what looks like a commercial area
or do we want to regularize this which
is what i think this planning
application is to deal with
and and the other policy chairman is
policy e1
and and that talks to the regeneration
modernization of expansion of existing
employment sites now it says
specifically existing employment sites
and then it goes through
a great big list starting at e1a to e10
of all of these
other employment sites which are coming
forward in the local plan
but it says quite clearly that we should
regenerate modernize and expand existing
employment sites that's policy
e1 and if anyone's got a copy of the ldp
you'll find that on page 65.
and then chairman going back to this
change of use from
agricultural to uh commercial i mean
policy e4 um you know if if we were to
accept this it was a very small parcel
of agricultural land within this within
this industrial site
then policy e4 says um
that you know we should where possible
and there is a need
um policy e4 says quite clearly that we
can actually
convert a piece of agricultural land
into commercial use
if it is applicable um so chairman based
on that and the fact that
there's no objections to this at all you
know i've read the report nobody's
objected
the people in the closest residential
properties haven't haven't
uh objected the parish council supports
this because they see
this site as an important employment
location for southminster
they support it chairman there is talk
about
uh the impact of noise but i think that
the applicant has submitted
a a noise impact assessment which is now
being found to to be acceptable
uh by with regards to what their
consultant is saying
but having said that they said they'd
mitigate it anyway so
chairman contrary to the officer's
recommendation i would propose
chairman that we support this
application and
we allow it to proceed because chairman
we should as council be supporting local
businesses thank you
thank you councillor bill
that's the bill would you like to
comment please yes thank you mr chairman
um i totally agree with what council of
fluke is saying and the parish council
this piece of land is not tremendously
large in respect of use of
agricultural and would be better used in
respects of these
application use at the uh that's being
applied
the land has never been of much
special use and in fact it helps well
with the
use of land for purposes
which we are trying to expand in any
case in the whole of the district and
that is
better use of uh land uh for um
the use as as suggested now um it's out
in the wilds as you might say so it's
not a lot of them the housing nearby and
what is nearby
is very very small the land itself
is better linked by roadway
to the outside world as you might say
and in fact
rather than have heavy lorries come
through the village or anything else
like that
it would mean that it be more localized
for that type of use
and would be better served in fact
as we've already agreed about e1 that
that's
now agreed but certainly i think it's a
better use of the piece of land
for the purpose which is being stated so
i would support this
thank you very much i i tend to agree
with both the board members
this site and the surrounding site is
being used for industrial for many years
and now i'll invite other members yes
chairman cast a channel
just to speak the channel
uh thank you very much chairman i'm
sorry chairman i'm hate to do it because
you are in the chair but i disagree with
you
and i'm afraid i do disagree the war
members although i have the greater
knowledge of myself
however i think the officer has got it
right because from what i can understand
from the report that
there's no real case why the storage is
required which of course as we know
we've refused other applications on in
the past when things have been required
stating
to help with business it's not because
i'm against business it's just that in
the past we've done it with other people
when they haven't come forward with the
correct evidence as to say why they want
something
and i believe that every bit of
agricultural land no matter how big or
small it is and the report is quite
specific
that by allowing this particular
development to occur
then it will um it will cause harm to
the the public realm outside and it will
have an effect
so i understand what's going on in the
site adjacent to if you like but that
doesn't mean to say you necessarily have
to extend that
to allow this to occur and i actually do
think from what my reading was
the environmental health still have did
have concerns about noise
and that that perhaps the what has come
forward hasn't totally
removed those uh all total concerns so
bearing that in mind i think regardless
of i'm hearing from counselor bill with
all due respect
about a small number of houses nearby
if there is going to in fact be a loss
to residential meaning to your harm
then i think that's something we need to
be absolutely sure of before such an
application is approved
so hence why i seconded your proposal
chairman that you put forward
that this be refused um and i seconded
that proposal of yours which you placed
uh because i do believe the office has
got it right chairman so i'm agreeing
with you
placing the proposal that this should be
refused and i seconded your proposal as
please chairman thank you
thank you for correcting me mrs miss
councillor channel
as chairman i have to move the officer's
recommendation
it might
that's fine that's fine we'll move on
any other members which
speak no chairman
right we'll move to the mo the vote the
recommendation is that this
uh f20 00459-ful
be refused can i
through chairman do you want any
response to any of those points raised
by members
yes if you want to do so please
before we go yep thank you chairman just
i think there's a couple of points
that's fine i just wanted to make some
clarity on um
council fluka made a point that this is
regularizing development this isn't
regularizing a breach and the
application form clearly states that the
use of the site hasn't started so it's
not a retrospective application in that
instance
furthermore the application isn't
submitted an expansion of a
existing industrial state or reliant or
through the development of that it's um
been edged red as its own so it is just
a new piece of industrial land
one of the better phrase that just
happens to sit next to an existing
industrial site
so it isn't an expansion in that sense
so any reference to the policies in that
respect i think
uh artificial um it is just a new
piece of employment land next to an
existing employment lands that is very
different to an expansion
per se um also cancer clinical
references policy e4 which um
relates to our cultural world
diversification and it states the
council will support the development of
new buildings or
activities associated with agriculture
and other land-based rural businesses
obviously b1 use or sorry b8 uses are
not
our cultural or other land-based rural
businesses they are something that
generally
can be located outside of um rural areas
for clarity um
and then the second part of the policy
relates to use of existing world
buildings
um and change use and where we'll
support that obviously this is an
application we change used to land so
cat policy for i don't think personally
really has much relevance to termination
of this application
um and i just want to echo the points
made by councillor channel in relation
to noise environmental health have
raised objection to this
proposal and um i agree with councillor
chana's point that really doesn't matter
if it's one person or a hundred people
if the uh
there is demonstrable harm to one
individual then that should form a
reason for refusal
and at the moment the council or the
local plan authority isn't confident
that there would not be some form of
harm to
uh immunity of some of residents
thank you chairman thank you very much
for that
before i move back to the vote does
councillor flucro accounts the bill or
councillor chandler want to come back
cancer stamp would like to speak
chairman and then counselor fluke would
like to come back
how's the stamp first please uh thank
you chairman can i wait for councillor
fluker to do his bit and then can i say
right
after him please yes you may captain
yeah thanks i just wanted to pick up on
this storage and distribution because
there are lots of farms that are working
out on the dng where they have
diversified their their farming
activities to
encompass um distribution and storage i
mean
um hall hall farm at south mints is an
absolute classic case
so i understand what matt lee's saying
but there are plenty of precedents for
this out there but
i'll give way to counseling stamp thanks
that's the stamp please
no my mine was actually to thank uh mr
lee for actually clarity and counselor
fluker
um i think this is a very difficult
decision to make and
i just thank them both for to be honest
with you clearing up a few queries i had
it's a difficult decision to make
chairman i'm afraid on this one but
thank you
thank you councillor bill do you want to
come back no i support what's being said
by members
okay yeah
i just wanted to just before members go
to the boy if the officer can just bring
back up the
the the aerial photograph identifying
the
um the allocations of the various land
use just so that members have in their
mind
the nature of the of of the area so
there is that photograph that you have
annie yeah if you can just
if you can just ex can you enlarge that
is there any way you can enlarge that
yeah well if not just just if you can
just just
just so that members are aware and then
i think
once you can see that if you can
identify the actual application site
itself
yeah um and how that is distinct from
the other areas also within the
applicant's
um ownership yeah which obviously
extends
down um i can't see how far extends on
i've got my bar
across the bottom but if you can also
just flip to the to the location plan
as again if you can can you go to that
again yeah so it just just so that we
can be quite clear of the nature of the
area around
and that the the employment side does
actually form a quite a discrete
um enclave of of employment uses
um located you know in relative
proximity to the road which is
obviously appropriate there and the
extent of
the countryside and agricultural land
that that is surrounding
and obviously as we just need to be
mindful in making our decision that
there isn't this encroachment because
clearly
the change of use um um
was obviously proffered by the fact that
there was encroachment
into that area um which it may be seen
by
other persons as to be part and parcel
of the employment use when it's not it's
actually encroachment
and and we could even see the best well
but the beginnings are further
encroachment going south
so we just need to be mindful when we're
making these decisions the delineation
of of employment sides
from you know the wider countryside
thank you chairman
thank you very much does anyone else
want to ask any questions before i move
on to the vote
yes chairman council fluke would ask
like to ask a question in relation to
the slide
thank you thank you and unfortunately
the slide has disappeared
i just wonder if mr johnson could pop
the slide up again
either one
lovely thanks thanks a lot mr johnson
i'm i'm i'm getting more and more
confused now because
the the area that's hatched in red
if you look towards the the left-hand
side of that chairman towards the bottom
and there's some
sort of orangey cunning color buildings
there all of those buildings are in situ
and all of them are being used for
commercial um activities uh
and some of them have been there for
absolutely decades
so i really am i really am um
surprised that the way this application
has come forward because
um as far as i was concerned the site's
always have paying that
uh planning permission to carry out
commercial activities i mean
could you could somebody identify mr
johnson perhaps could you show us where
this proposed
um unit is to be built
uh if i can just defer to miss king to
identify on the appropriate slide
and if you could do that please it would
be good if you could yeah so it'd be
in this area here so nice
so this is the proposed building
which will be about here on this plan
okay chairman i'm i'm really grateful
for that because it appears to be within
the cluster of buildings that
are already there you can you can see
them on this location plan
so um you know i you know i still look
towards policy one and see this is the
regeneration modernization expansion of
an existing employment site if it
doesn't have planning permission then
i'm
absolutely um confused but i still
support the application chairman because
it's you know it generates employment
and and it's a great thing and i think
what council of bill said
you know having something like this in
the middle of the village or whatever
um you know and let's be honest we've
just discounted an employment site
in the middle of burnham um for
residential so
yeah okay chairman i i'm as i said i
know this site well and i am confused
but i still support it
okay thank you very much right we'll
move to the uh
sorry apologies chairman cast of china
would like to come back please
um thank you chairman having had that
put up by the officer again
i i saw something there uh i think i'm
correct
um saying that no planning permission on
something
could we just see that on the screen
again chairman because i think that's
quite important and it might be what
council of luca
um is now fight you know having a bit of
surprise about
so there's no evidence of planning
permission for those
buildings that are indicated those two
large and there's limited site history
regarding another so we don't
could that mean that that hasn't got
planning permission or it does on that
third
building
thank you chairman yes i mean it's it's
it's it was important for us to identify
that
this site seems to have just you know
grown of its own accord and encroached
into the countryside yeah
and obviously it's the purpose of the
planning process to to
to manage how this particular growth so
we're concerned that just because there
may be these dispersed
uh buildings which may have been used um
to then suddenly become um formalized
through the planning process for further
industrial uses
in the countryside the applicant is
quite clear that
um the proposal is for a change of view
so
there are no doubt themselves that
planning permission is required
i mean on on the the other slide the
aerial photograph
even further than the red line site you
can see a few dispersed buildings i mean
you know my question is you know you
know will they come in later on to say
well there's these buildings here and
they've been there for so
long and clearly there's no planning
permission there so we need to have
regard to the plan in history we need to
have regard to the lawful use of sites
but
making these determinations and also
have regard to our policy and trying to
protect these sites
thank you chairman chairman when i come
back with a supplementary on something
um
where where the where um the planning
officer indicated the
the uh storage thing was to go she
seemed to imply to me it was going where
some buildings already identified
and yet when i look at that application
um
site thing we've just seen uh which i've
gone back to saying
there's no planning permission it seems
to be on its own i can't see
the buildings it would be going in or
replacing um
so i'm not i'm a bit confused
can i have an answer for an officer
please
that's michael sorry no use
okay um as far as i'm aware i
think these are containers down here so
they're not
um building as as such okay so they'll
be removing the containers that are
there and replacing with a purpose-built
building
okay and the containers haven't got
permission
not that i'm aware of right thank you
thank you thank you chairman are we all
finished burner
chairman
chairman can we just can i just ask
would that be an enforcement issue
rather than a planning issue for this
meeting chairman
well someone's applied for planning
permission we have to decide yes or no
so you chairman um just sent yes
councillor stamp the uh application is
before us as it is the applicant accepts
that there is not that the use of the
land is agriculture
so any use that is in conflict with that
would be a breach of planning control
which obviously is a
separate you know isn't it isn't the
matter finished for discussion and this
but it's a point of clarity that you
know the applicant has myself and mr
johnson explained
has quite openly accepted the
application that the law for use to site
is agriculture and not for anything else
thank you mr lee i think that's
important thank you
nice to meet councillor
um how long have the buildings been
there do you know and
and i can't see if if the parish council
are in favor
and it is an employment issue what is
the reasons you know
because we should be with parish council
as well shouldn't we because they live
locally
so you chairman um the buildings
that have been discussed on the and you
know ms
keenan's johnson has already spoke about
are not subbed
on this application site or subject to
this application we're just highlighting
that
we are unable to find any planning
issues it appears that the
use of the site for employment has grown
you know organically without planning
permission and probably
um at one stage been breach of planning
quite possibly now lawful through the
passage of time but that's a separate
matter
um in relation to for one of a better
phrase going with the parish because
they
they know best that's not how the
planning system works
um we are here as decision makers to
determine a plan application accords
with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise
that means we have to starting point is
our policies
and whether or not a proposal conflicts
with policies
we consult parish councils just like we
consult public and other interested
parties to get their input and that is a
material consideration in the
determination application
but agreeing with a parish council
because
or anybody else just on principle is not
the way that the planning system works
it has to be looked at against our
policies and
as explained this at the moment is
agriculture
the applicant has put this forward as
its own site it's not expansion existing
employment site
there's no evidence to say why it should
be here remembering that our policies in
relation to employment
needs to evidence that if we're going to
go outside to certain boundaries
outside the allocated sites we need to
be evidence why there's a need for that
and there isn't
anything as part of this application
that backs that up it appears to me for
one of the breakfast but it's adjacent
to a past the land that the applicant
owns and therefore for his ease that's
there but the planning system is quite
clear that that isn't how it works just
like with the sequential trust with new
dwellings and things like that
so we need to look at the planning
policies and go through that as a
starting point
it is the parish council that know the
area well isn't it
and also nobody's been against it
nobody's written against it have they
no local people do you chairman um
i'm very concerned about the assumption
that just because you know the parish
haven't have it think it's okay all of
members and the council should think
that's okay
we are here as a decision maker we are
here to assess an application against
policies that's the starting point
um just because the parish support
something should not be
or objects to it conversely it shouldn't
it's a consideration but it is not the
format the fundamental part of
determining plan application
and case law is clear in relation to
determine application the level of
objection or support for an application
is not
a uh material consideration and actually
the point in relation to this is
actually and what the judge says when he
actually does
the assessment on this point is that
us as decision makers are to make the
correct decision based on policies based
on evidence
the public quite often will not object
on the assumption that
the decision maker will make the right
call and they're either they don't want
to have
arguments with the uh neighbourhood they
might not want to
uh they might not know enough et cetera
so just because someone doesn't object
doesn't mean there won't be harm and as
i've explained
in our environmental health department
who have looked at the situation have
concerns about the impact on immunity of
neighbours so
if we grant planning permission and
there is an impact on those immunity
they may want to object them but it will
be too late we're here to make the
correct decision
at this time we can't retrospectively go
back and
correct an error we make thank you
chairman
thank you mr lee can i ask a question to
you mr lee please
assuming we go through with the
officer's recommendation
where are all these businesses meant to
go to have we don't allocate a site
where they can go to
three chairman i'm not quite sure what
you're talking about we're not this
application relates solely to
the parcel of land it doesn't relate to
the businesses that are
occurring there are people there and if
this is refused
they will have to shut up shop where
they're going to go
well this i said so the applicant is
indicated this isn't a retrospective
application
and the buildings etc that counts uh
sorry not councillor
ms keane and mr johnson looked at and
explained that's not subject to this
application so
grinding plan efficiently not quite in
planning permission doesn't impact on
those existing sites okay thank you
thank you very much mr lee
i'll move now to the recommendation i
think councillor
has another question right that's the
fluke yeah thanks jim for letting me
come back so
you know i'm getting more confused i'm
you know at the end of the day if mr lee
is saying this has got to revert back to
agricultural land it's been in mind to
the south it's bordered by ashland brook
and there's no access there
one side is a commercial land we've
established that the other side is
residential
um and i susp gemini
i'll hazard a guess but i would say 90
of this site is covered in concrete
so you know reverting it back to
agriculture
in my mind isn't isn't an option i think
mr lee said something quite interesting
when he said
they might be able to prove through
investment action that whatever's been
going on there has been going on for a
long long time
um and that we may not be able to
enforce because of the history on the
side
but chairman i still think we should be
pragmatic about this
and uh we should um support this
application
mr lee would you like to come back
uh through chairman um when i was
talking about enforcement action i was
talking about
the query in relation to the buildings
to the east off the cuff
so uh the applicant is quite i think if
the applicant thought that this was
immunity enforcement action they would
not necessarily be submitting a lawful
development if they would have submitted
that rather than
a new application where they acknowledge
it's the law of his
law for uses our culture and and
chairman if you just let me
chairman if you let me just come back
and ask councillor myself
i think you are um but chairman
if members were mindful to prove this
could it be on the condition of a
satisfactory
noise uh condition
um if members were to approve this
i would recommend that there was some
sort of condition in relation to noise
the issue is that guidance is that we
shouldn't be
putting on conditions such as that if we
aren't confident that they can be
overcome
and there is certain to use your phrase
cancer fluke we should take a pragmatic
approach to
the protection of immunity of neighbors
and
matters such where we have may have
concerns about the ability to
for it to be overcome we shouldn't be
imposing conditions that are
going to floor the permission so
therefore the applicant should be
providing us enough information that we
are comfortable with a condition could
overcome the harm
and they haven't done that in this
instance so irrespective of the
principal issue and whether or not you
think the site
on aesthetics could be allowed to be
um a little you know if you think that
the use of land for employment isn't
going to cause harm to the countryside
you know there's no aesthetic harm if
the principle of the development is
acceptable
members should still potentially look to
refuse the application just on noise
because that would be the correct
planning approach to
the master thank you chairman okay i
think i've got council hall have a
burner
no still has her hand up but cancer
channel i just wanted to check if she
had a question and counselor chandler
has a question
cancer channel please oh thank you
chairman
but it's really it's really in like what
counselor fluker raised and i think mr
lee's answered it but council fluker did
then mention about
saying a load of concrete being on the
site and reverting back to
um reverting back to agriculture
my understanding is in listening to mr
lee quite clearly
i felt mr lee was saying the app and the
application says it
that it is about um change of use of
agriculture
so therefore councillor fluke has said
reverting back but to my knowledge from
what's been said
and the applicant's view it's already
seen as agriculture so there's no
reverting back
this is a change of use from agriculture
to banging this storage um container on
am i right on that because um regardless
of the fact if there's concrete all over
it or whatever
it's recognized by all it appears to be
that it's agricultural
for you chairman um yeah i'm just going
to say yes there's not much more to say
to that council channel
thank you very much everybody for your
debate i'll now move on to the
recommendation to refuse
berna can you take the vote please thank
you chairman so we're voting on the
officer's recommendation
if that fails we go back to the council
of luke's recommendation
if i'll call your names in alphabetical
order if you can stay clearly for
against abstain thank you
council passenger uh for the officer's
recommendation
thank you councillor beal against
officer's recommendation mazda bell
four has the boys
against pastor channel
uh mr lee has been so clear in his
advice
i'm for the officer recommendation of
refusal
counselor fluker against
helm um
i'm uh two minds to i'm i'm worried
about the loss of employment and
where the people are gonna go so i'm
gonna go against the office
recommendation
which is a very very unusual i'm afraid
councillor hall
against
cancer schemes for
the stamp full
thank you chairman that's five for the
officer's recommendation
five against the officer's
recommendation and no extensions
i suppose i've got to use a casting vote
overnight
yes i will go against the office of
recommendation please
so we have to take another vote on uh
that's right moving this recommendation
and we want
uh conditions please
counselor can you give us some reasons
please
that's the fluke
sorry chairman um um
gemini i don't believe that this will
given its location i don't believe it
will
cause demonstrable harm to the character
and appearance
of the site and the intrinsic character
character the countryside because of
where it sits
german it's 16 what something is all
everybody's always accepted has been an
industrial area so
german i don't say it's i don't see it
as contrary to policies s1 s8 d1 and e1
of the design guide and javen
as far as the noise is concerned i hear
exactly what mr lee says
um about you know it's not a good idea
to attach a condition that has to be
satisfied by the applicant
but i think in this particular instance
chairman i think we should
we should actually attach that condition
and then we can leave it up to the
environmental health people
and their agent who understand my
understanding is from an email from the
agent which i think has been sent to all
members
that that had actually been satisfied so
i think that's something we need to do
to clarify chairman through a condition
uh
and chairman i've made a proposal and i
think councillor bill
has uh seconded that council lee would
you like uh
sorry mr lee you don't want to be wrong
thank you so much well i would would
like to point out for clarity
i know it's not really probably too late
now but hadn't had this raised
the application currently doesn't
according to the applicant have any
employment
uh workers on site there is nobody
that's what the applicant has stated in
the application they have they've not
filled anything about
that according to them there aren't any
so that's the point of clarity obviously
that
okay um do you need any more uh
conditions or anything um
is with the fairly broad statement
council fluke was said about this it
would almost imply that you know this
could grow exponentially so i think you
know just uh
conscious of that that would be the only
guidance i would say in relation to
council flukes
reason for approval you know the matters
of such as is their impact on harm
are subjective in character the area to
a certain extent and
to a certain extent you know as
officers said you know they consider
that the policy is conscious to policy
but you know i think members
can't stand planning principle where
council flew because
direction of travel with his reason for
approval he's coming from but i said it
just
is a little bit broad for my liking um
in relation to the condition
i have concerns um i don't think members
should be taking face value
emails from applicants and that's not
comment on this applicant
this is a comment in all planning
applications you know things should come
through offices
um and obviously aaron barton health are
still objecting so i wouldn't agree with
what
the applicant has stated this and but as
always my advice would be irrespective
of this application
members shouldn't necessarily be quoted
in taking verbatim
uh correspondence directly had with them
because this hasn't gone through the
due process and hasn't been validated by
officers
uh thank you chairman chairman mr
chairman
yes thank you mr chairman we haven't
looked at hours of operation
is that important at the moment to say
what time they could use
the site and for the purpose suggested i
believe that is councillor
mr lee chairman um
to be honest if members were to grant
planning permission for this application
i would
be suggesting that uh conditions are
delegated to officers because obviously
schemes such as this are quite
challenging and complex and have the
potential to have
real and demonstrable impact on immunity
of neighbours um
open storage remembering that this would
be is a can't blanch
uh open application which you know
something such as storage of uh i don't
know scaffolding poles
um at six in the morning moving it then
would call we'll be able to travel a
long way and cause a lot of harm so
officers would want to with negotiation
discussions with our environmental
health team
come up with hours of operation and we
wouldn't obviously want to have it
24 7. but i would suggest on an
application such as this if memphis
grant
approval is that it's delegated to
officers and
discussion with yourself as chair
council helm thank you
thank you mr lee your normal app uh
hours are eight till six and eight or
one on the saturday no working on
sundays
and now working on bank holidays would
that be sufficient
not as you said that's normally our
hours but i would always want to just
double check off the cuff you know
there are sometimes material situations
but that would normally be the case
that's why
at the moment it was delegated but we
would probably come back with something
so this this was uh now we're taking the
vote for
yes chairman counselor stamp would like
to speak please
yes please chairman can i ask mr lee
could this also involve
a like a container or a lorry park that
you could have all sorts of huge
things coming in and out i'm just really
concerned that this this
v8 could be absolutely anything and
we've now got no control over what be
could be coming in and causing a
nuisance whether it be a
noise nuisance or a traffic movement
news
i'm sorry i'm chairman i've got the
wrong teeth in a nuisance at the moment
chairman i'm a little bit concerned
about this can mr lee help me
um i'll do my best counselor stamp um
the applicant has applied for
um a b8 use um
in relation they've stated storage of
sorting of inner waist
um there's the potential to
impose conditions that would tie that
down if thought appropriately but that
wouldn't
preclude the idea that there would be
quite large vehicle movements quite
large
um issues but that's one of the reasons
why officers had grave concerns and
suggested the second waste from refusal
there's a lack of clarity to ensure that
there wouldn't be harm
um it's difficult because obviously
that's why officers put had that
concerns that's what the officer's
report explains you know
the potential from harm from that but
obviously members
didn't agree with officers so it's hard
for me to give much more advice than
that because
i've already provided my professional
advice in that matter but i don't know
if mr johnson wants to step in and if
you want michael johnson yes please
michael johnson
yeah um just in terms of the um
the question pose i'll just sort of draw
members attention to
5.1.10 of the report that just gives a
a discussion about um
the um the
noise report uh submitted um
there was actually a an inconsistent in
terms of um
what was submitted and the nature of the
application it says there it is noted
the noise report submitted to the
application
says that the use of the site is
retrospective and the
skip hire business currently operates
from the site with up to 12 deliveries
occurring per day
i mean obviously that's inconsistent
with with the application
form submitted by the applicant in term
that this is not a retrospective view so
there are obviously some issues there
which we are concerned about and hence
leading to
to to the to the recommendation that
that we made
but just in terms of that specific
question there are it's a skip hire
business we know what that involves
there's up to 12 deliveries a day
um the way the things are on the table
uh following um members position
is that there is no particular control
over that it says 12 it doesn't
necessarily
mean that that there will be 12. and
what is the nature of that what is the
size of those containers
it it could be large containers this is
an open sided structure so there's a
whole number of issues
that could come out of the wreck of this
recommendation thank you chairman
thank you very much are we all finished
chairman caster channel would like to
ask a question
by all means um thank you councillor
helm
um i'm sorry i'm not getting more
confused because um it was said
and i know it was a separate issue mr
lee made it clear we heard that if this
uh didn't go through then where are all
the other people
where are all the people gonna go on the
site it could have ramifications for
them
and yet mr lee has pointed out now that
apparently
there is no employees on on this
particular site this is sought for
so um that to me both there is
agricultural land
there wasn't employees on that so it
won't have any ramifications necessarily
for the
other businesses and therefore um that's
why i still maintain the office's
original refusal was the correct one
especially in light of what we're
hearing now
and inconsistencies i'm i'm quite
concerned chairman
actually about this now well it can
still go down
madam chairman uh councillor channel
we've still got to go through the vote
you know people can vote against if they
want to yeah
for clarity chairman on council
channel's point um yeah my response was
in relation to
the premises around and what the
application stated
and i thought i had been clear but
obviously wasn't clear enough that
according to the application you know at
the time
that this is not lawfully an employment
site there is no
employment land according to the
applicant occurring on this site
quantity application forms
obviously i wasn't clear enough at the
time due to comments made during the
voting process but yeah the applicant
has clearly on the application forms not
filled in the section about
number of employees on the application
has clearly
stated that um the
site the application is not
retrospective so those are the matters
that officers have assessed it on which
is the application has submitted and
that is
as decision makers the way we should be
assessing it
not on how we feel or what our opinion
is it should be based on the application
before us
thank you chairman thank you very much
bernard will move to the vote please
which is to approve with the conditions
uh
stated by councillor fluker can you take
the vote please
chairman with the reason yeah sorry for
for the reasons stated by council fluker
and the conditions delegated to officers
that's correct
the chairman thank you thank you
chairman uh members
i will take your take you in
alphabetical order can you stay clearly
for
against abstain counselor bassinger
i'm sorry burn i'm rather confused again
i think we've just voted and now we're
voting
again for we voted for sorry council
bastard we voted
for the officer's recommendation of
refusal and that was refused
so now we're voting for councillor
luke's proposal to approve
the application contrary to the
officer's recommendation which was
seconded by
councillor beal and for the reasons
outlined
uh with conditions delegated to officers
in discussion with the chairman
so if we refuse are we refusing the
application again or are we just
looking at with conditions on it i'm
still confused i'm afraid
is it just me if you don't want this to
go through you say
refuse or against if you thank you
and minded to approve you say approve or
for
okay thank you uh refuse
i'm afraid i have to go for sorry
paul
thank you chairman that's five for the
recommendation
five against no abstentions
with a heavy hand i have to uh do the
casting vote for
i'm sorry why do you you don't have to
at all
you don't question the chairman sorry
i can question the chairman of course
you can question the chair
i'm sorry i'm the chairman and i'm not
being questioned on why and what for
you said with a heavy hat you're sorry
why are you sorry
no because i'm going against the
officer's recommendation
and using my own knowledge to vote
thank you right we move on to now twenty
double o
five four nine o ut land adjacent to
sixty four
south mr road tillingham found on pages
55 to 56
in a moment i will call our officers
to present this item members are
reminded if you wish to speak on this
item please make this known
using through burner within this meeting
i will then come
you in turn and please keep your points
clear and excellent
uh miss keenan would you like to present
the
application please is that the right one
well on the right page
it's mrs staple housed i believe okay
thank you thank you chairman
okay this application is for outline
permission
for one three-bedroom bungalow two
applications have been refused
previously on the site which i will
speak about later on
so this is the location plan so you can
see
um these are some residential sites um
to the east of the application site
and then some open fields to the west
this is the block plan and showing the
indicative
positioning of the dwelling which shows
how it would sit behind the prevailing
building line along
southminster road where properties are
characterized by their frontages
directly onto the road
so this application follows two
previously refused applications
the 2016 application was for two
two-story dwellings and was refused due
to its sighting outside the settlement
boundary and the impact on the character
of the area
and also due to the access having
unacceptable visibility
so you can see this is roughly what was
proposed under that outline application
uh the previous 2019 application was for
one
two-story dwelling the concerns in
relation to visibility were overcome
however it was still refused due to its
sighting outside the settlement boundary
and the impact on the character of the
area
these photos show the view of the
entrance to the site
here and the house would be positioned
roughly here
this is the view from where the house
will be roughly sited
um south of the site and this is the
view um to white horse farm across the
road
the view east along south minster road
and here's the site
entrance and the view west and the house
would be positioned
behind this fence behind these sheds
here
due to the sighting outside the
settlement boundary and behind the main
building line
the proposal would cause harm to the
character of the countryside
the previous concerns have not been
overcome and therefore the application
is recommended for refusal
thank you chairman thank you
um planning application
2005 490 ut land adjacent 64 southwest
road tillingham
recommendation is to refuse the reason
sec
now section 8 if any member wishes to
second the motion
please turn on your video unlock your
microphone
and state your name now please
boyce i'll second it okay thank you very
much
councillor boyce members who would like
to comment please
and nobody's indicated at the moment
chairman
councillor fluka has i think no
he's indicated he's indicated that he's
no more
questions um i'm sorry bear with me he
does
google yes yes thank you thank you
that's the question
cast please yeah thank you very much
chairman
and and thank you councillor stamp as
well
um chairman first of all can i can i
just clarify that i am a member of
chillingham village council as they are
known
um chairman the parish council supports
this application
um principally because they think that
it fits in well with the location and
that there's no detrimental
effect on the neighboring countryside or
the area
and um chairman i'm sure you'll remember
that we agreed
a simmer a similar application at the
haven which is about a half a mile
to the west a couple of years ago but
chairman
what i wanted to do before i speak to
any policy i just wanted to speak to a
recent appeal
um which members would have seen arrive
in their inboxes
this week and it was in relation to
rosedale cottages malden road
uh in the north of the district just
before you get to tiptree and what the
inspector said there was
and he granted a permission on appeal
for two properties
in the countryside and i agree that it's
it's a much different type of
application as far as the fact i think
that they were already built
um but what he said was we should only
gone
uh where the intrinsic character of the
countryside is not
adversely impacted on so this is all
about
is this going to be impacted or not the
parish council like me
we believe that where this bungalow's
been
located with proper with proper
screening to the west
you wouldn't even see it as you came
down what we call the denture straight
we wouldn't see that um and i think
chairman also i think it's worth
mentioning that
whilst the parish council supports it
there have been no letters of
of objective objection so
and then i think the inspector specter
then goes on says as long as it's
compliant with other policies within the
ldp so
um you know is there is there a need for
this type of dwelling well it's the
three-bedroom bungalow and i've heard
earlier
on chairman that um that we have a need
for two-bedroom properties but of course
it could be a two-bedroom property with
a study
and that would tick that box we know we
know we have evidence to know
from what's gone on at south fields in
uh
in tillingham blackwater reach in south
minnesota that bungalows are an absolute
premium and i know
councillor beale has always has always
said how important it is to provide
bungalows in the district
and the other thing chairman that i
wanted to just speak to briefly is
sustainability because i think the
office said it wasn't a sustainable
location and of course this
this fits in with satisfying
the uh the requirements of the ldp
when we look at policy sa so um
first of all chairman you will know
because i'm sure you go down the
dendrite straight an awful lot there's a
wonderful footpath
adjacent to the highway that goes all
the way to tillingham and when you get
to tillingham
um obviously there's a shop there's a
doctor's surgery there's a school
and two pubs and lots of other
facilities including a convenience store
and which i think i mentioned anyway but
the offices alluded to the fact that the
dart is a responsive service well
chairman i
i didn't think it was because i'm always
seeing the d4 buzzing around tillingham
and other villages
and so i did a bit of research on this
chairman and and if if one goes on to
the provider's white website
and there's another company that
provides this information as well
that there's actually five return
journeys a day
between bradwell and burnham so
i thought it's a bit odd that the
officer said there wasn't because when i
when i checked this site which i think
is called
transport move it or something it
clearly shows it
uh and funnily enough i saw one of the
buses this morning when i was in
tillingham
so chairman does this really affect is
does this really affect
the intrinsic value of the countryside
and the beauty but i think where is
german it's tucked away
it provides a much needed bungalow for
tillingham and the parish council
supports it chairman
and that said um chairman i i can't
support
the the officer's recommendation i would
propose that we
actually agree this recommendation thank
you
thank you chairman um pull your hand yep
that's fine i don't know if anyone any
other members wanted to speak before i
came back
from these points yes the caster voice
would like to speak
i'm happy to you know if i'll come back
on some points after council boys have
spoken
yet please
um thank you chairman um
i came um looking at the agenda
predisposed um to um
go along with the officer's
recommendation on this
which is why i seconded
um your your proposal
um to refuse i can remember the history
of this site um going way back
and i've argued uh
very forcibly in the past that that
there shouldn't be properties
on this site however
council of fluker has actually put some
doubts in my mind um
i mean i know uh mr lee has
said um that the parish
council are only a consultant um we
shouldn't really we should go with
policy
not um uh what the local
people wish but council fluker has made
some compelling arguments
for me to reconsider
and at present
i am not so sure that i will be voting
against this
um i will need to perhaps see what the
rest of the debate um uh says on it
thank you chairman
cancer voice in the meantime would you
like to withdraw your seconding of the
motion or not
no i'll wait to finish
let's start giving you the opportunity
anybody else please
no chairman not at the moment
well if there's no further uh i'll go
with the uh
matt recommendations sorry you were
going to come back won't you
sorry mr lee so i think council stamp
just sits you on
yeah um i think we've got to be in
danger of um i mean how many times have
we sat on this
this committee where it says you know we
pay for planning
officers uh but because we have eloquent
councillors who've maybe been around for
many many years and know the way around
the system is far
better than other councillors who maybe
aren't so established
i think we have to be really careful
that we're going to go against another
recommendation
of the officers it is outside the
development boundary
and it's i'm sorry chairman all this
picking and choosing because we know or
we don't know or whatever
we choose whoever we want to support at
the time it's very dangerous and we're
setting a dangerous precedent here
and i i actually i actually feel very
strongly
himself what's the point in having
officers that we pay them for if you're
going to try and
and stop having i tried to get something
called a different committee
and was short sharply shot down by taxes
and so i do think we need to be careful
here i haven't got any reasons
to um support the
uh council of lucas wanting to support
it and i really think we need to support
our officers and recommend the refusal
it's there for a reason and and
councillor boyce has and i've heard him
in the past when i've attended meetings
not as a councillor
really go and not want him in telling
them and they've thought long and hard
in telling them to stop over development
and here we have we've got another one
um
who who they want to overturn you can't
keep picking and choosing members thank
you chairman
thank you councillor stamp any uh
councillor uh
mr lee please
i think councillor howell now started
the question so yes master holland
council
and council sorry councillor fluke would
like to come back on this as well but
counselor hull has her hand raised
yeah well they've cancelled the whole
first house
i just think it's very it's it's we
should take
notice of our accounts because
often these are the
i can't hear what she's saying chairman
no i can't either at the moment
oh near the microphone okay
you're very distorted i'm afraid i
haven't got a very good response
chairman if we could take maybe council
futures come back question and then
see if the whole reception in the
meantime members don't interrupt when a
member speaking you should have your
microphone off thank you
councillor fluke please um
chairman i'll give way to mr lee thank
you and then
mr lee please
thank you chairman um firstly i just
would like to reiterate
that as decision makers we cannot
illegally delegate our decision to
parishes and just be supporting their
presumption and although they may have
more of a local knowledge
we are here to determine and plan an
application
in accordance with the development plan
as material considerations indicate
otherwise
and that is point of case law point of
planning legislation so
i just want to reiterate that that is
how the planning system set
up um firstly though i'd like to
secondly then move on to councillor
fluka's point about the site being
sustainable i
think it's a very dangerous statement um
there is not good street light and it's
not good
uh access to day-to-day facilities
remember in that
as the office's report explains that the
site is
relatively close to uh tillingham isn't
it and but that is a smaller village
um it's not one of our larger segments
anyway and furthermore
which i will go into slightly further
this has previously been refused twice
for this information
um and
and the point about the dart bus
actually comes from us it's counter
council
information but that's a slightly mute
point such i don't think
um a small number of buses per se will
make this a sustainable sight in
compared to others and it'd be a very
dangerous position
just to say this site is sustainable
because this would be something that
every applicant would be able to echo
and use against
or or in favor of their applications um
in relation to the paris support as once
again you know
we are here to assess application in the
country ldp unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
members will know i've said it millions
of times to slightly exaggerate but
one of the biggest material
considerations is
planning history planning permission has
been refused twice on this site
both on sustainability impact on the
character area
and certainly the layout in relation to
the street scene and urban grain that
should be a material consideration that
members
take into account and give substantial
weight the council has previously
refused to applications on this site
um the fact is this application is a
three bed bungalow there's no way of
stating conditioning that it could be
two and that they'd be using as a study
and even if as their members will know
because i've explained this before even
if the current
applicant did want to use it as a study
there'd be no way of that being
retained and insured long term so the
application should be assessed as a
three-bedroom property
and their strategic housing market
assessment
clearly indicates that we need one and
two beds and not three
beds so i think those comments by cancer
fluid should be given a limited weight
council also raises the recent approval
or allowed appeal um that came in i
think on friday
and i think it's it's fair point that
all members
know that we should take into account
decisions by inspector
but i think it's very important also
note that this was an application that
had been given planning permission
previously
what had happened was similar to the
first application actually so
if anything this is this approach the
inspector has taken sort of echoes what
the conversation we had on the first
application
um this was a site that had been given
planning permission um
development had been undertaken without
the conditions precedent being complied
with so therefore the lawful planning
permission
fell away the council didn't
particularly have an objection to the
proposal
the unauthorised development but what we
were actually more conscious was that
conditions had fallen away so things
such as surface water
and uh foul conditions car parking etc
no longer existed on that site there was
no way to ensure that the harm was
mitigated so that's the main driver
behind the council taking enforcement
action um
but to reference this one as you know
council okay clearly thinks that this is
a very very
uh similar development if ms staplers
can pull up the location for block plan
for me
that'd be helpful
as members can see here obviously there
is a line of development along
south minster and this site is clearly
located to the rear which obviously does
not
reflect the urban grain of the area and
importantly with the one that council
flew preferences on friday that came
through
it says in paragraph 16 of the
inspector's letter
this part of maldon road is
predominantly rule in character and
sporadic housing and ribbon development
including
where the appeal site is located
remembering these are retrospectives
they actually are on site already
and a builder's yard lies immediately
next to the appeals site beyond the yard
there is a charm foot
farm shop sending various procedures
produced with a garden center and coffee
gift shop
to the rear a detached wedding lies to
the south of the appeals site and there
is
a dwelling farm to this shot so the
point is that this was a
basically an infield plot on a ribbon
development this proposal clearly
does not fall within those lines this is
a building behind the existing
uh run of properties along south minster
it's creating
something outside the urban grain and i
think
looking as you can see from the plan in
front of you if we were to accept that a
property behind
this site is acceptable and taken into
account
the fact that all of a sudden we're now
going to say developments outside of the
settlement boundary
in a not particularly you know you know
i would think an area that is going to
be very
reliant on car park is now sustainable i
think members would need to be very
conscious of this precedent
and the potential them for applicants in
relation to 64
68 or sorry 60 56 etc all coming in with
similar proposals and looking at this
scheme i could see no reason why
officers would be able to say if we're
accepting a scheme here why they
wouldn't be acceptable
and you know members asked me quite
regularly in relation to areas such as
stony hills
when how do we stop these form of
development and when is it
when are we able to draw the line in the
sand the point is actually in planning
is that you join the line in the sand
before you allow the first one
because every applicant has a reasonable
expectation to have their applications
judged fairly
and consistently and taking into account
as you can see here on this plan
if members were to allow a dwelling
behind this
in this site outside of the urban grain
and say it was sustainable
i'd be very difficult to look to
be able to not support applications
behind 64 60 etc
provided there was an impact on their
amenity space etc so
i do have a lot of concerns about this
scheme and
i also consider that the highlight in
the
previous appeal decision on friday is
very limited way and if anything
goes against this application not for it
um
and that yeah that matters such as
saying this could be a three because
they might use one as a study
material situation we can't give weight
to and i have real real
fundamentally growth concerns about
trying to argue this site is sustainable
because um it goes against what
officers and members have decided on
numerous applications around
the district thank you chairman thank
you
anybody else anybody else burner
councillor would like to come back on
that and then council stan would like to
ask a question chairman
this is the last
look you know the reason why i referred
to this appeal because it spoke
specifically to policy s8 and uh
and and i've said enough around policy
essay and how how you deal with that
but i would say that as far as i can
recall the two refusals on this site
were for two-story props to this
chairman they were houses
which visually impacted and the parish
council uh
objected to those um and i hear what mr
lee says about sustainability but of
course when he made his
when the officers made their decision
and they were under delegated powers
i did wonder whether or not they have
had the information available to them
that local members and the parish
council has
um it's a 10 minute walk from this
property to the middle of of tillingham
where all of the facilities are that's
actually quicker than going from bali
meadows in south minster
up to nissa so uh and i've already
spoken to
the facilities that are available and as
fast lights are concerned well the
street lights now at south fields
which is about 200 meters down the road
probably not even that
it's a very wide footpath chairman and
i say that it's a sustainable location
and when this committee
when this committee approved a new
residential
property at the haven which is i think
about a quarter of a mile or so
to the uh west going away from
tillingham
uh members said that that was a
sustainable location
uh so i'll pocket there chairman and uh
i won't be coming back but i have made a
proposal thank you you will not be
coming back
thank you oh there is now i hope you're
not bullying me
that's the stamp please um yes thank you
chairman
um i actually would like to support the
officer mr lee made a very very
um valid well-rounded and it's very true
and and i think we need to listen to him
it is outside the development boundary
and you can bet your bottom dollar into
a packet of a pinch of salt or whatever
the old saying is
those houses next door and next door but
one will come
following on so i support um the
officer's
recommendation to refuse thank you
chairman
thank you very much for that council
stamp uh we moved to the office of
recommendation
which is to refuse for the reasons
detailed in section 8.
we have a second for that can we go to
the vote please
thank you chairman members can you state
clearly for
against our abstain counselor passenger
sorry for the officer's recommendation
refusal council ambassador yeshua
thank you cancer beal
abstain
four boys
four
for refusal the officer's recommendation
castle fluker
against the helm
for the
against council skins
for refusal stamp
thank you chairman that's seven for the
officer's recommendation two against and
one abstention
so that is refused we move on to now to
our favorite location
one stones park stoney hill burnham on
crouch
planning application 20 double o double
five
to ful found on pages 67-80
in a moment i will call on the office to
present the ice and members
a reminder that you if you wish to speak
on this item please make this known
to burner and i will then come to you in
turn
please you think your points clear and
success
and please do not speak over somebody
else during the meeting
which has happened twice or three times
now
mistakeless please present the report
thank you chairman this
is a retrospective application for two
dwellings
uh firstly please note the members
update which has the
town council response and a further
public comment
an application in 2016 approved
permission on appeal for three houses um
on the application
site here and on this piece of land uh
just to the north
and these dwellings were of a slightly
different design
an application in 2018 approved
permission for the third
northern dwelling so the dwelling that
would have been on this piece of land
um for an amended design which is of the
same style to that proposed under this
application
the two dwellings on this current site
have been built without discharging any
of the previous conditions
from the 2016 application
this application has been submitted to
regularize the 2016 application
the conditions and the design amendments
made
the amendments relate to the design of
the dwellings and the garages as set out
in section
3.1.4 of the report and also a verbal
update um the internal amendments relate
to
minor ground floor layout changes and
the reduction from five bedrooms to four
the fifth bedroom is now a bathroom
so here is the location plan and showing
the site
where the two dwellings are located and
this is where the
third dwelling that was approved in 2016
is located
here is the um proposed block plan and
showing the access coming from stony
hills to the site
with the two plots and the two garages
here
driveway and parking to the front and
the amenity space and to the rear
and then you can see here again the
third dwelling um
approved in 2016 which has been built
here
so this is the block plan from the 2016
application
and showing all three dwellings um
so this was the dwelling that was
approved again in 2018
for design amendments similar to that
proposed under this application
these are the elevations um for plot one
um where you can see the design
amendments
and so they consist of um the front
projections
these two on either side and they've
been altered from
a hipped roof to a gable roof with an
increase in eaves and overall height
by 0.5 meters and the front
center projection has been increased in
eaves and overall height
by 0.6 meters rear projection has been
altered from a hit
to gable end with more glazing up here
um and the removal of um some juliet
balconies to the rear
so you can see the the amendments from
the previously
um approved application in 2016.
these are the current floor plans
of the dwelling on plot one
and these were the floor plans approved
in 2016 so it's just this fifth bedroom
here that's been
changed to a bathroom
so here are the elevations of the
dwelling on plot two
and so the amendments relate to um
the rear projection has been um
extended by one meter at first floor
level and altered
from a hipped roof to a gable end with
glazing in the apex
there's been a removal of a rear juliet
balcony and
minor fenestration alterations in
relation to the windows
which you can see in the previously
approved plans for plot two
the proposed floor plans
and the previously approved floor plans
again with the bedroom that's now a
bathroom
these are the proposed garage plans
and the previously approved garage plans
so the hip roof has been altered to a
gable roof
here you can see um the view north along
the access leading to the the houses
here
um view from the access south towards
stony hills
and these are the dwellings we've got
one plot two
view of the one of the garages um and
then the neighbor to the north
uh which already has approval
it's noted that the original application
was approved prior to the adoption of
the ldp
however it's not considered that the
main thrust of the policies within the
emerging and adopted ldp
have materially altered in a way that
would mean the application should be
viewed differently
particularly as the inspector for the
2016 application
considered that the development did
comply with policy d1 in terms of its
impact on the character of the area
um in relation to rams as set out in
paragraph 5.8.3
as the construction of dwellings at the
site was approved in 2016
without the rams requirement and the
fact that the development is almost
complete
it's not considered that the approval of
this application would result in any
increase in demonstrable harm
as the development is in place and
therefore is not considered reasonable
to require
a rams payment in this instance
overall given the history of the site
and the surrounding area there are no
objections to the principle of the
development
there would also be no harmful impact on
neighbours and the design amenity space
and parking are considered acceptable
it's therefore recommended for approval
thank you chairman
thank you very much ms staplehurst
under council's public participation
scheme we received one submission from
the agent
in line with the public participation
scheme i've reviewed the submission and
an officer will now read out
uh allocating two minutes only to
reading the submission in accordance
with the scheme
the submission is from neil cooper the
agent
michael johnson please thank you
chairman
dear members the owner of the site
instructed us to prepare revised
drawings
in february 2020 for the alterations
that are before the committee
our plan our planning advice at the time
was they were likely to be approved
subject to a planning application for
the following reasons
the proposals in their entirety and the
small addition to number two stones park
and the size and relation of them to the
new scheme approved on plot three
stones park which is owned by another
developer
were minor in comparison all of the
garages in stoney hills
are gable ended as opposed to hip ended
and plot 3 stones park at their triple
garage with gable ends
so the change from a hip to gable on a
much smaller garages should have been
acceptable
the changes before the committee were
all quite minor
and had no additional impact on the
neighboring immunity
and were all planning policy compliant
at local and national level
after instruction unfortunately we lost
some staff due to covered furlough
and one of our operators had discussed
with the owner that they were carrying
out the alterations and submitted them
in july the applicant called asking for
copies of the relevant permissions
and we had to tell them that this had
been overlooked due to the furloughed
staff
we subsequently submitted new plans
albeit late
as the contractor had carried out the
alterations assuming they were approved
whilst it is understood that the
applicant should have waited
we can only apologize on their behalf of
their misunderstanding
i hope members take these comments on
board in determining this application
alongside the fact that planning office
planning officer recommends
the small amendments for approval and
understand
that as an agent we are responsible for
the mistake on behalf of the applicant
but hope they will see that these
amendments for the original plans are
minor and comply with planning policy
and that the scheme for one and two
stones park
are still minor compared to that already
approved at number three stones park
and would respectfully ask that the
amendments are approved
in this case thanking you
thank you chairman thank you very much
i'll move the recommendation
that is to repo approve subject
conditions
as detailed in section 8 of this report
if any member wishes to second that
motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
anybody
boyce i'll second it thank you that's
the boys
um obviously members want to speak on
this
which one do we take first berna which
one we got first
sorry when you say which one you've got
first what
we've cancer stamp wanting to ask
yes how to help give way to counsellor
hull if you wish you can go ahead and
then cancel the whole coming afterwards
okay um just for clarity just a quick
question to the officers
um and maybe help some other members so
has
has this these two properties been built
unlawfully without the council
permission
and does that have any effect when it
was actually approved in 2016. chairman
did the planning permission run out
i understand the rest of the argument
that the uh
obviously the precedent's been set i
just want clarity if that's okay with
you chairman please
officer please
uh yeah through your chairman i can um
go back to that um
so as discussed in the principal um
section
um because the dwellings were built um
without having discharged any of their
pre-commencement conditions and we don't
consider that
that permission the 2016 permission is
extant
um so that they have been built without
permission and that's why it's been
brought forward at committee and been
advertised as a departure
thank you chief airman did you want to
come back counselor stamp
can i come reserve to come back later
please chairman okay fair enough
councillor hull
do you chairman i think there's a second
point to councillor stamps query though
has picked up on and about whether or
not that affects the
uh assessment um yes it does
um obviously not having an extent
permission
is much less of all having previous
permission but no longer being live so
there's not been extend permission
obviously there's less for material
consideration than
if there is an extent permission if
there is a live permission on site
and that obviously affects the balance
of it
but what also affects the balance is the
assessment of when planning permission
was granted
and as ms stable hurst explained in the
presentation
the inspector found no harm to this form
of development
which is something you know we've found
numerous inspectors to find
at stony hills no matter whether
officers have recommended approval or
refusal when they've gone to appeal i
mean their members haven't agreed with
our recommendation for approval
and that's i think is the important
point in this is that
when assessing the scheme although it
was before the adoption ldp potentially
not sure before we had a five-year land
supply the inspector when looking at
this scheme
found no harm irrespective of those
points rather than
giving weight to our lack of our
five-year lands by the overcame those
harm
thank you chairman thank you
councillor hull
sorry to be
we can't hear you at all councillor hull
we'll have to move on to somebody else
is there anybody else
no chairman nobody else has indicated as
yet
can we try again could you put it in the
chat bar chairman
excuse me not she's on screen now
counselors
hopefully she can thank you castle
and what i'm concerned about they
haven't been built at all have they
these houses but they have been built
but without permission
can you hear me council look at mr lee
would you like to answer councillor
hull's
questions for clarity um
planning fishing has previously been
granted but because of condition
precedence weren't cleared
um and the development has taken place
that extent permission has fallen away
um so legally they have been built
without
planning permission because the planning
mission was never complied with
um i hope that but it's not a case if
they've just randomly gone in the field
and built two houses if that's what your
question is thank you chairman thank you
anybody else council do you want to come
back
yes please does it does it mean if
if they don't get permission they'll
appeal to us again and the council will
have to
lose a lot of money on it
do you chairman taking into account
they're on site i think if
they're built on so i think it's very
likely the applicant would appeal
um second point that question i think
it's a bit of a moot point
we should not be refusing schemes that
should be granting
appeal so we shouldn't be we should
definitely not be refusing schemes if we
think there's concern that we'll get
costs that appeal because the only
reason we would get cost is if we've
been unreasonable which would mean
we haven't determined the application
because of the development plan as
material considerations indicate
otherwise
and i would hope as a committee and as
an authority we'd always do that
thank you chairman anybody else
not at the moment chairman unless cancer
hall wanted to come back again i thought
i heard her say something but i just
said thank you
thank you okay thank you council hall no
nobody at the moment
chairman that's the last we both move on
to the
uh recommendation uh seconded by um
councillor boyce i believe determined if
i could come back didn't i
oh sorry councillor yeah i did and you
said it was okay chairman
yes sorry that's my mistake i apologize
um what uh what i would like to say and
i think this is cancer flukes whether
he's in or out at the moment he's having
issues
logging in and out we are where we are
um i actually do
like the amendments that the uh the
the developer has done and um
we can't go back on it the precedent has
been set we all understand that my only
issue
is that they haven't followed process
and procedure but that's down to the
council to sort out
but i actually uh will be supporting
this chairman thank you
thank you anybody else
right i'll remove the recommendation
that planning application double five
two ful one stones park stoney hills
burnham be approved subject
conditions and detailed in section eight
of the report
uh can you uh take the vote please
bernard
yes chairman can i just say before i
take call the vote that
uh counselor fluke was indicated he had
connectivity issues so he won't be
taking part
in the vote i i am correct unlike
councillor fluker
yes that's really correct so can you
just record that accordingly under the
the uh virtual meeting protocol because
i can't
it's not just the case abstaining i
can't vote thank you
okay thank you very much for that
counselor very honest of you thank you
okay so for the officer's recommendation
of approval
can you please state clearly four
against abstain
councillor bassinger four
bill four
bell four counselor boys
or counselor channel or
cancer helm four hustler hull
thank you chairman that's eight four one
against no abstentions
let's carry it then uh we move now to
item 10 uh planning application
2005 777
full for land adjacent 20 chapel lane
tilliam found on pages 81-96
please note the members update in
relation to the application has always
been
circulated prior to the meeting in a
moment i will call on officers to
present this item
remember as a reminder that if you wish
to speak on the item
please make it known to berna
and i will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succulent and do not speak over somebody
else thank you
uh well i've got the right one here
20 chapter 10 sorry i've got several
papers in front of man it's a job to
catch
keep up with it
we've come to the office in there to
present the uh
application please thank you chairman
sorry i'm a bit confused there because
the page turned over
this application is for two
semi-detached dwellings
um and is a resubmission from a
previously refused application
the previous application was refused due
to the design
the shortfall in parking and in relation
to rams
the dwellings have been reduced in
height and are now of a chalet style
the number of bedrooms has been reduced
so there is no parking shortfall
and a legal agreement has been submitted
in relation to rams
please note the members update which
confirms the agent has submitted a legal
agreement in relation to rams
and has um further consultation
responses and public comments
um firstly i'd like to point out um on
this plan
this brown line shows where the
conservation area
is positioned and so the site here is
outside of the conservation area
and the specialist in conservation has
no objections to the proposal
which can be found on the members update
so this is the location plan i'm showing
the site outlined in red
on the northern side of chapel lane
which is accessed via
south street
this is the block plan showing the
positioning of the two dwellings
with two parking spaces to the front of
the site
and the amenity space to the rear and
this tree um to the rear is shown to be
removed
and however a condition has been
included to ensure its retention
and that building works don't damage
this tree or
this neighboring tree either a condition
has also been included to ensure a
walk-over ecological survey is
undertaken prior to commencement
to ensure there are no harmful impacts
on ecology
these are the elevation plans um
so the houses have been um reduced in
height and
i now have a chalet style rather than
two-story
and so these are the plans from the
previous refused application and you can
see the reduction here
the proposed floor plans showing the
reduction from four bedrooms to
three bedrooms meaning that the two
parking spaces provided would be
sufficient and the previously refused
floor plans with the four bedrooms
and then the proposed street scene plan
and the plan from the previous
application
to show the amendments made and that the
dwellings would be in keeping with the
scale of the other dwellings within the
street scene
photographs west along chapel lane and
towards the application site here
and again the view of the application
site
and some photos of the neighbor to the
east number 20
a view of the sites and the neighbor to
the west
overall the proposal is not considered
to result in material harm to the
character and appearance of the area
or neighbouring occupiers there are also
no concerns in relation to immunity
space or parking
and therefore the proposal is
recommended for approval thank you
chairman
thank you miss titlehurst under the
council's public participation scheme we
have received two submissions
one from rejector and one from the agent
in line with the public taskation scheme
i have reviewed the submissions
and an officer will now read this out
allocating two minutes only
for reading submission in accordance
with the scheme
michael johnson please
thank you chairman we are janet
and david beard of 20 chapel lane the
neighboring property
and are objecting to the proposal for
the following reasons
one a building of the proposed size
scale and design
is not only far too big for the plot but
will not be in harmony with the
conservational aesthetics of the north
side of chapel lane
and thus will not enhance or contribute
to the street scene
in any way two a building of the
proposed proportions
and close proximity being just one meter
from
our border will have a substantial
impact on our quality of life
it will overshadow the side of our
bungalow that faces it
on this elevation we have four windows
and a glazed door
through which we get the majority of our
natural light and sunshine
which provides a great deal of internal
warmth
we also enjoy relaxing on the patio area
along that side and the proposed
overlooking bathroom window
although obscured glass will be
regularly opened
three with the proposed dwellings there
is potential
for eight private vehicles this would be
unacceptable
in a small private lane where parking is
already at a premium
and as it is also a public footpath the
safety of pedestrians
and animals would be put at risk point
four
this area enjoys a huge amount of
wildlife and it is proposed to remove a
beautiful
mature walnut tree there are further
trees
and a large wildlife pond to the rear of
the property
thank you chairman thank you
submission too
thank you this is uh
mike otter the agent good afternoon
members
the points raised in objection by
tillingham
parish council and representations from
neighbours have been comprehensively
addressed
by the malden district council planning
case officer
in the committee report it remains
therefore for us to confirm
that a great deal of thought has gone
into the design and style
of the proposed development to
complement the mix of surrounding
properties with particular consideration
to the ridge height
of the main structure and a single story
feature to the rear of the properties
also beside elevation fenestration
our clients actually have a beneficial
interest in number 24
the western most adjacent shelley
dwelling which
naturally has given them a greater
personal incentive
to present an attractive development
whilst retaining
untouched the pond and its natural
surroundings which is also in our
ownership
they are more than happy to retain the
walnut tree which was originally thought
to be a potential problem
but this is now no longer an issue we
would refer the members to the plan
attached to the committee report
which clearly shows that the distances
between the two adjacent properties
are considerably greater than all of the
other dwellings
for quite some distance down the lane on
both the north and south sides
most of which have gaps of between just
one meter and virtually zero
the distances dwelling to dwelling east
and west of the proposed development
are 5.8 meters and 10.3 meters
respectively
we would like to record our appreciation
of the planning officer support for this
application
and would welcome similar favorable
consideration from the committee members
many thanks for listening mike otter for
gpo designs
thank you chairman thank you very much
for that uh the recommendation is set
with the report is as follows the
planning application
2005 ful
land adjacent 20 chapel lane tillingham
be approved subject to sign
a uniatal undertaking to confirm that
development will contribute to the essex
coastal rams
and conditions as detailed in section 9
of this report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
i'll meet your microphone and state your
name now
anybody
have you got anyone burner well we've
got constant
caster fluke would like to speak on this
item but uh we're waiting for a seconder
if unless you want to carry on now
we don't necessarily have to have one
chairman
chairman cancer sample secondary thank
you very much cancer stem it's very good
of you
so council cooper is ready cancel the
fluke
please
that's the fluke please are you still
there yeah i
am indeed yes um kevin i i'll
uh i'll just say this um first of all i
think mr otter the the applicant
or the agent on behalf of the applicant
um i think he said that he worked really
hard with the
uh with the council and the parish
council to uh
get something that was acceptable but
general and i can confirm as a member of
tillingham village council the
application that we
considered is actually the same one
that's before this committee
and you will see from the report and uh
and
we've already been told that basically
how much weight we should give to the
responses from
parish and village councils for mr lee
so we don't have to go through that
world rehearsed argument
but they do not support this chairman
and the reason why
is the chapel lane is a is an
interesting road it's got some quite
interesting properties in there
the conservation area does extend to the
other side of the road
so it's diagonally opposite but i do
hear what mr halsen says is fast the
fact that he has no objections to this
but chairman i think if councillor duke
could attend these meetings during the
day and i'm sure he'll be delighted
um to attend the next one which i
understand will be starting at six
o'clock when he's not working
but i think he would have been this
would have been his argument that this
is like fitting the quark into the pint
pot
and chairman i i don't think this has
improved much
um there are you know there is there are
different properties in chapel lane it's
an unadopted road
it's got some you know it's got some
nice features some nice properties there
and either side of these properties are
detached houses chairman
and and going back going back to i think
what mr lee said you know we've got to
be very careful not to set precedence
because
i know that the one next door's got a
garage and something else and we can see
if we suddenly allow
semi-detached pairs of semi-detached
houses we're going to have problems
so chairman i i would propose chairman
that based
on what's been submitted by mr lotter on
behalf of his clients
the this application is refused under
policy d1
and chairman i just expand that because
you know there's an awful lot of
policies sub-policies in d1
so german my view is it does not enhance
the character of the local context to
make a positive contribution
in terms of architectural style the
height size scale
for messing and proportion i still think
chairman in relation
to the street scene is too much um the
layout the orientation and density is
covered under
policy d1d and finally chairman
i don't actually think this will
contribute and enhance the local
distinctiveness
so i would propose german at this
application as it stands at the moment
as
a pair of um semi-detached houses
that it's refused under policy d11
a one b one d
and one eight and i i i understand what
mr lee says but you know we really
should listen to our parish councils
thank you thank you councillor fluke for
anybody else please
banner yes counselor channel and then
councillor schemes
yes oh thank you chairman
would it be possible please to see um
i've listened to
what the object had to say and concerns
about um the effect on their immunity
could we see perhaps um block plan again
and be pointed out where the objective
is and where the proposal lies and
distance between them
that's if that's possible chairman
um so um number 20 is this this site
here
um so i believe if you can actually see
from
some of the in this photo you can just
see it is their
driveway and sort of car parking and
garage that is
sort of about the um shared boundary
with the application site
um but what they appear to be talking
out is talking about is um
a sort of patio area here um which
they've stated that um
they sit out at um but it would be the
driveway that would be
located adjacent to the boundary we're
going back to the block
plan and also like to point out that
this would be the single story rear
extension so it would just be this
element that would be two
story as well yeah um and what's the
distance between the two properties
the planned and what's there in
existence
um so the distance to the boundary is
one meter
but would be um 5.8 meters
to the to this part of the house correct
me if i'm wrong i think the report said
9.8 meters did it
and 10.3 meters for the other side but i
think um
like mr johnson when he read out it did
say 5.8 but am i correct the report said
9.8
or something around there um that would
that would have been for the western
neighbour on the other side number 24.
not well i thought i read 9.8 and 10.3
in the report am i wrong um that is
correct but it's in relation to the
other neighbor
so um so this this one here so
what's the 9.8 then and what's the 10.3
in the report
well have i read it wrong so it's number
24
chapel lane so the neighbor to the west
would be 9.3 meters from the
shared boundary with the development and
10.3 meters from the proposed western
dwelling oh
right okay okay now i'm clearer okay
thank you
so there's no habitable rooms then on
number 20 that would be affected by
the development it's purely appears to
be with a proposal the bathroom window
that they claim
even though obscured would be open a lot
um there is a bar there would be a
bathroom window on this
elevation and but there is a condition i
can't remember what number
um that states it has to be um
non-openable
okay and would there be other windows on
that elevation as well
um so just the ground floor window here
which would be
shielded by the fence right
okay thank you how's the channel anybody
else
burning uh yes like caster skins
uh just to say that i found myself in
complete agreement with uh councillor
fluker
uh i think this is a a pint being
squeezed caught being squeezed into a
pint pot
uh and uh i find myself inclined to
disagree with the officers on this thank
you very much for that anybody else
no chairman not at the moment i'll move
to the recommendation then the planning
application
twenty double o five double seven full
landing james
twenty chapel lane tillingham be
approved subject to assigning
unilateral undertaking to confirm that
development will contribute to
essex coast rams and the conditions as
stated
as detailed in section neither is report
this was seconded by a council stamp i
believe
yes go to the vote please
before we go to the voters can i just um
let the
uh commit you know that councillor bell
and cancer boyce have left the meeting
okay okay radio thank you thank you
council
against the boys carry on burner
council berlin councillor boyce okay so
this
can members can just uh please state
clearly for
against our abstain for the officer's
recommendation of approval
thank you councillor passenger against
against master channel
um sorry i'm in a bit of trouble just
opening up my i'm
muting myself um against
fluker
hull oh i think she probably
has actually left me
i think she has left the meeting members
uh
councillor schemes uh i've never
forgotten
uh the bear with me for a second i'm uh
against the officer's proposal
uh listening to the debate i'm going
against it
thank you members that's six sorry
none four the recommendation six against
one abstention so that has failed
that's failed yes do you want any other
vote on anything else for that or is
that
it on that well chairman yes we have to
now because that failed
don't we have to um give reasons
no we need we have to read the rules and
with reasons
but council didn't counsel who can make
a proposal
yes chairman caster fluke made a counter
proposal
i'll second his proposal well secondly
by councillor schemes we'd better take a
vote again then please
with reasons please gemini if you let me
come back i think uh
the the reasons that i've proffered all
relate to
policy d1 uh and in respect to
policies d11 a b d
and uh policy eight uh i beg
policy d one eight which is all around
design quality and the built environment
thank you
and that's what's seconded by councillor
skins berna can you take the vote please
okay thank you so this is
a vote um contrary to the officer's
recommendation
of approval to refuse the application so
members if you can state clearly for
against drab staying counselor passenger
oh
oh cast of chana
four castafluka
for the reason given by counselor fluka
we move on to any other items the
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent
i have none uh members thank you for
your contribution and thanks for member
of the public for listening
i never drew the meeting to a close at
15 23
thank you very much